(car engine whirring)
(car door opening)
(car door slams)
- Eric.
Wait.
Are you sure you want to go in like this?
- Yes.
- Are you sure you're sure?
- Yes!
Why? What's wrong with it?
(car honking)
- Wait a second, please.
When I first came to this country--
- Dad!
- I had to do so much to fit in.
(sighs)
I never wanted the same for my children.
- Okay.
- I wanted you to be proud and strong.
But you are so different.
It makes me feel scared for you.
- Your fear doesn't help me, Dad.
Makes me feel weak.
- But why...
do you have to be so much?
- This is me.
- I don't want you to be hurt.
- (scoffs) I'll be hurt either way.
Isn't better to be who I am?
(car honking)
- I told you to wait!
I just shouted at that man.
- Yeah. (laughs)
Yeah, you did. (laughs)
- Maybe...
I am learning from my brave son.
(gentle music)
- Dad. (laughing)
(high heels clacking)
- [Adam] What the fuck did you
come as, Tromboner, a girl?
- [Eric] What do you want, Adam?
- I'm gonna fucking kill you.
- Okay.
Are you gonna do it now or later?
Because I'm ready when you are.
- It's comin'.
- Okay.
So later then?
Great.
(upbeat music)
(high heels clacking)
♪ I've gone away forever ♪